Okay.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
This is so funny.
The egg man called in and left a voicemail
basically saying, I I'm jealous that I have
sour grapes, that I'm not a homeowner.
Uh, on the basis of a story we did on the
bonus show yesterday saying, Hey, home ownership
isn't necessarily all it's cracked up to be
and listen to the incredible attack from the
egg man saying, that's my view.
Only because I am not a homeowner.
Take a listen to this.
I think your take on renting versus buying
is a salad grapes because you don't own a
house is pretty much horse looked at.
If you say the return is only like 2% after
you subtract all those taxes and property
memorial, all the repairs and stuff, who cares?
You're making arguments that home sellers
aren't even trying to make.
Okay.
Here's the deal, Dave.
I bought a house 15 years ago.
I paid it off.
Now I bought another house.
When I sell this house, I get all that money
back.
It's all mine.
The whole house I paid for, it's all my money.
15 years of renting.
When you move, what do you get back from that?
Nothing.
I don't know.
If you know what it feels like to get on your
mower and cut your lawn and then sit back
and look at it and have a cocktail or a glass
of wine and just see the property that you
own.
You might have to pay taxes on it every, every
year, but I'm Dave, you're just missing out.
We're not trying to make money on our houses.
We're trying to get our money back.
I'm poor white trash.
I paid off the house in 15 years.
Now when I sell it, all that money's mine.
I've never had that kind of money before,
so I'm just guardian people from buying a
house is very, very silly.
You have to take risks to get ahead in life.
You'll never get ahead of you
renting.
You always want to be mobile and able to go
from place to place.
You're going to be living out of a backpack
and a couple of these of furniture.
Get some roots, man.
When you own something, you plan routes.
I'll also had kids, goddammit, as long as
you're not a kid anymore, have children, married
this woman, get a house with a yard, get a
lawn mower with a big deck.
Learn how to pick weeds and stuff and teach
your kid how to uh, you know, be a good liberal,
shallow, rather love you guys.
Oh Man, egg man.
You know, I don't even know how to respond
to this other than to say everything he said
is wrong.
Um, I have been involved in multiple real
estate transactions.
I do own a house.
It does have a yard.
I do know about picking weeds and mowing the
lawn and all of this stuff.
And what egg man seems to be missing is if
anyone is out of place with their comment.
Egg Man's talking about paying off a house
in 15 years and it obviously being more logical
than renting.
Egg Man lives in rural upstate New York, which
is extraordinarily inexpensive.
Good luck trying to pay off a house in 15
years in Boston or in New York City or in
San Francisco.
And the point of the whole story that we were
talking about on the bonus show was when you
calculate how much you made on a house, if
that's what you're doing, doesn't mean you
have to.
Um, it's important to take out of that all
of the interest you paid on the mortgage.
If you buy a house for $200,000 on a 15 year
mortgage or even a 30 year mortgage, you're
not actually paying 200,000 for it.
You're paying a multiple of that because of
all the interest and you just have to account
for that.
When you consider your profit margin, when
you sell, you have to consider the cost of
the property taxes, which you paid during
that time would, you wouldn't if you're renting.
So if anybody doesn't understand, I think
it's the egg man, number one.
Because I'm involved in multiple real estate
properties currently and I know all about
what the ag man's talking about, but most
importantly, he has a very rural America centric
view of how this stuff works.
And all of the discussion we had was that
in many cases, there are advantages based
on cost of living, based on age, based on
mobility desires and all sorts of different
things to not being a homeowner.
I am a homeowner.
I understand the pros, I understand the cons,
but please Akhmed very weak take because you
don't know what you're talking about.
Um, uh, do I
have anything else to say to the egg man?
I guess not just Shalom and I hope, hope you
had a good, uh, Passover.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member, become a patron.
We'll speak to you though